we've got a few high clouds out there
beautiful skies a little bit of color
we're going to have more color in the
sky and more clouds as we get through
the day
we're looking for temperatures to get a
little milder actually as we head
towards christmas i think santa's going
to have a pretty nice flight but the
closer we get to christmas the more
unsettled our weather is going to get
we've got 37 at centennial hills and
downtown 27 in nellis though coolest
spot in the valley 30 in seven hills and
27 out at red rock outside of the valley
to the west a little breeze at kyle
canyon we're really not looking for much
in the way of wind today there are a few
iffy spots if you are traveling today to
get a jump start on the holiday i think
the later we wait into the week to
travel is when things are going to get a
little
really dicey we've got rain around
dallas but boy once that rain meets the
cold air that's in the mid-south look
how quickly it turns to snow in
southwest arkansas and southern oklahoma
rain for new orleans and along the gulf
coast today back into the west the first
in a large series of storms
this one is getting bigger it's kind of
stalling and stretching out in the
pacific sending rain and snow in the
northwest there are some winter storm
advisories and warnings that have been
posted for the west but what's
interesting is it's going to tap into a
lot of warmer air down here in the
pacific and those clouds will start
heading our way as we get into later
today into tomorrow and the first half
of the week we'll have clouds and milder
temperatures before we really get a
taste of these storms in the west it was
great though to see skiers and
snowboarders out on friday when lee
canyon finally opened and they're going
to get more snow from these storms
moving into the west when they're done
in california with it but boy beautiful
17 inches of snow last week and that was
enough for snowboarders and skiers to
get out elite canyons now open seven
days a week so that's great news and
that's nine a.m to four p.m every day so
if you want to get up there and try out
the bunny hill it's open for you we're
looking at 55 degrees today with
increasing clouds cloudy clouds and
sunshine today for our last day of fall
winter starts tomorrow morning and when
you know it things get milder best
chance of rain now comes thursday with
mountain snow slight chance left for
christmas eve and then another system
brings us a chance for rain again on
christmas day with mountain snow in the
forecast slight chances left for sunday